so consider the following situation
you're a data scientist working for some
organization you have collected some
danger or you have access someday to do
some data that you want to make
available to others but you're worried
because the data set contains
information about people and you think
that some of these people might not want
to have this information public what I
want you to get away with from this talk
today is an appreciation of the threats
that you face when publishing not
properly anonymous data and an idea of
the tools that are available to you to
better anonymize data what I cannot give
you unfortunately is a fixed toolbox a
set of steps you just need to follow to
have a proper anonymized data set and we
will see why this is the case there's
many reasons for why you want to polish
data currently there's a strong movement
towards getting our governments cities
other organizations to publish data
about their work for accountability and
transparency reasons in this case the
city of New York published data set
containing millions of taxi rights
information on where the taxi ride
started where it ended and even how much
tip was paid and this data set was used
to make fancy visualizations like that
to make analysis on which part of the
city's underserved by cabs or even just
to find out if there's likelihood that I
will get a cab at 4 a.m. in the morning
when leaving my friend's home the data
set contained reference to attacks the
ID but not in raw form but it was md5
hash to make sure that you can't
identify their actual cab problem is
there's only a limited set of possible
taxi IDs in New York so somebody just
sat down Auto generated all the IDS and
the 5 hashed all of them
cross-referenced with the data set and
within that 2 hours that person had
completely D anonymized the data set and
then you can think of funny situations
like get taking a paparazzi photo that
somebody
taken off a celebrity getting into a cab
taking the cab number from that photo
and figuring out where the celebrity
went and even how much they paid in tip
publishing data is also very common in
the sciences if a researcher publishes
the data set that they make based their
results on than other researchers can
check that these results indeed are
correct and can even build their own
research on top of them there was one
very famous data bridge in Massachusetts
so dataset containing health information
that is information about a person for
example date of birth and their zip code
who came to the emergency room and what
kind of medical problem they presented
with was in this data set
the data set did not contain any social
security numbers or names or other
obvious identifiers but a researcher was
still able just by going by
cross-referencing this data set with the
voters list to identify the governor of
Massachusetts from that data set this
case made huge waves and a bunch of the
methods I'm going to be talking about
today we're kind of sparked by this case
also legislation has changed since then
so if you want to publish medical data
in the u.s. today you have to follow
some stringent rules and something like
this could not happen today I want to
talk now a little bit more about what we
mean by sensitive data what is what are
the threats that could face the data and
then I want to get a bit more practical
let's take an example data set and let's
go through and analyze it it is quite
obvious that when you talk about
anonymization then you talk about
removing information and now we also
want to look in this talk on the utility
left after anonymization is it worth it
is it even worse publishing the data set
afterwards then I have some bad news and
that is that some of the of the methods
that I'm going to talk about in the
first part of the presentation are not
going to
work for some very common datasets so
I'm talking about some alternative
approach as well and finally I want to
finish the talk with some practical tips
and standards what do we mean when we
talk about sensitive information well in
case of the medical data breach I guess
most of you would not be happy to have
information like that publicly available
that people can just look up in the data
set
what kind of problems you went to the
doctor with but what is sensitive to you
in many cases is not sensitive the other
to others and the other way around
saying what what is considered sensitive
even has some cultural component I guess
most people in this room wouldn't be too
happy to have their celery information
publicly available in Sweden on the
other hand your information on how much
taxes people pay and by extension how
much they earned in a year is publicly
available information and things like
what taxi I where what where did I take
a taxi or what books did I rent or what
movies did I watch is not necessarily
sensitive in itself but it can give some
hints on my hair on my behavior and my
habits on my political ideas today I'm
going to have a few assumptions that are
that this talk is based on number one we
are talking about publishing raw date or
microdata
not statistics the what is good with
publishing microdata
is that people can make visualizations
they can make their own statistics about
the things that interest them and they
can even apply machine learning
algorithms maybe there's some predictive
modeling possible with the data set and
privacy requirements for microdata are
obviously much more stringent than for
statistics so it's a much harder problem
to solve number two we want to minimize
the risk for privacy breaches and we
sing we say that we think that everybody
has the same risk the same
equal right to privacy we will see that
datasets often contain some smaller
populations in particular older people
are at risk and we want to protect them
just the same and we say that our
adversary is smart is resourceful has
access to other datasets might use
technology that we are not aware of and
this part warrants some more getting
into so we think that our adversary will
have access to additional data in
particular interesting is if the
adversity knows that the target is in
the data set that is a very very helpful
information the adversary might have
additional data sets that could be
demographics public information cutoff
will also be private information that
they may might even have gotten through
illegal means
and the adversary might also have
personal knowledge about the target also
bear in mind the adversary is not it's
not a black and white situation your
adversary could just as well be a
journalist who wants to find proof of
the wrongdoings of a corrupt political
politician it turns out that you need
very little information about the person
to uniquely identify them in the US 63
percent of people are likely to be new
uniquely identifiable if you just know
their date of birth if they're a man or
woman and their zip code if you have
this three information about somebody
and you know that person is in the data
set there's a 63% likelihood that you
will be able to find exactly that person
and this is exactly what happened in the
Massachusetts data set the researcher
she had these three pieces of
information and could just look up the
governor in the medical data set let's
look at this plot on the x axis we have
the age of American inhabitants on the y
axis we have the percentage that are
likely to be identifiable let's consider
first
blue line that is the lower line and
remember we said on average it was 63%
that are likely to be uniquely
identifiable we see here that up until
60 years of age the lines closely
follows that average but there's a sharp
increase for all the people and that is
just there is fewer of them around if
you are 90 years of age it's very likely
that in your zip code you are the only
person bought with that birthdate the
second line the green line the one in
the middle shows you the likelihood that
you are that there's only one other
person who has exactly the same setup as
you and we're reaching 90% in many
demographics finally the top one the red
line shows the likelihood that there's
up to four other people just like you
and basically we have covered nearly
every American inhabitant now I actually
I rerun this number for Germany as well
and we we fall into a similar percentage
ranges here and because of what I just
showed you information like age
education ethnicity are called quasi
identifiers they are not identifiers
such as name but as combination of those
is often enough to uniquely identify a
person let's take this as our example
data set for the second third of the
talk let's say your researcher you went
out ask people if today was Sunday which
party would you vote for and you note
down some demographics of the people
that you asked and you know down what
they would vote for and now you want to
make this data set available to some
other researchers we can see here for
quasi identifiers that's per if it's a
man or woman the age of the person the
location where they live and their
profession so if somebody knows all of
these four things for example about this
man who is 27 year old lives in Leipzig
and works in sales if you know that this
person
is part of this dataset you can uniquely
identify him in by just looking into the
dataset looking for his quasi
identifiers and we call this attack a
record linkage given the quality
identifier information you have you can
point to one or very few records in the
data set and to protect ourselves we can
just say giving given a combination of
quasi identifiers we want that several
that this combination points to several
records in the data set
particularly we want to have it at least
K records and this combination of course
the identifiers we're going to be
calling equivalence group for the rest
of this talk so let's get back to our
data set we have X yeah so right now we
have a K of one because in this case
every record every group is just one
like with every combination of quasi
identifiers available you can uniquely
identify one of the seven people in this
data set so let's try to anonymize that
and raise K to 2 and we have a bunch of
ways I'm going to talk about two today
that is generalization and suppression
so our sales person from Leipzig maybe
it's not that important that he is from
Leipzig maybe it's just good enough to
write Saxony and maybe then we can group
him with other sales people from
different cities and Saxony we can also
generalize other attributes for example
numerical attributes who can like age
you can put into nice ranges so instead
of writing that our sales person is 27
you say our sales person is between 25
or 20 and 29 or is between 20 and 29 and
we actually see in our data set we have
another sales person also from Saxony in
a similar age range so we should just
could just go ahead and move this and
then generalize both attributes age and
location so they are not no longer their
exact age they're between
in 29 and live in Saxony we have two
others were quite similar they're both
women in their 50s who live in
Heidelberg and work in some kind of
engineering we can generalize this as
well
we have these two they're not super
similar unfortunately the only thing
they really have in common is their
profession so if we do this we're going
to lose a lot of information we don't
know anymore if there are men or women
we only know they're in between 40 and
60 they work in some kind of craft and
they live in Cologne and finally we have
our nurse 23 from Potsdam and she
doesn't really fit in with anyone and
maybe it is for the better in this case
to just suppress her record from the
data set and whether to go with
suppression or generalization of course
there's always different options so
maybe for the last two we should have
suppressed as well maybe that we would
have kept more information the data set
in this case so when you run algorithms
for example for K and an immunization
you can often say how much you want to
suppress how much if you want to
generalize and you give some thing that
you want to optimize for example you
want to optimize for information loss so
yes every combination of course the
identifiers that is in the data set is
now in groups of two so K is to success
but we have a bit of a problem because
in this equivalence group both people
would vote for a and you don't need to
be a genius to figure out if you have
this information about your friend from
Heidelberg that she would vote for party
a so we call this attack and attribute
linkage you cannot point pinpoint to
some specific record but this is the
distribution of the sensitive attribute
in the data is such that it's very easy
that it dominates the equivalence group
and it's easy to figure out the
sensitive value so you can call now for
L diversity meaning there must always be
l distinct values for each of the
sensitive attributes in an equal
equivalence group so in this group it's
fine
there's two different parties if you
just know that your friend from sexy new
who works in sales is in the data set
you you have you don't really know if
they would be working for voting for a
or C but as we said here's a problem in
this case we have an L equals one and
remember how we said that everybody has
the right to the same equal privacy well
we need to go with the worst case
scenario here then the overall data set
has an L of one so let's try to
anonymize that such that l equals two
and one way to go we could for example
generalize further a group these four
together and we kind of lost most of the
information content of the data set and
we're not even save yet because we have
an L equals two but 75% three-quarters
of these roles vote would vote for a so
you see we still have a dominating value
for this equivalence group so there's
also what is called t closeness so the
the distribution of the attribute over
the equivalence group should be quite
similar to the overall distribution that
means if the overall distribution of
party a is 75% then that should be fine
the problem is kind of this is what we
set out to find out right we wanted to
know which different demographics vote
for which different parties and if we
now say that every equivalence group
should follow the oval distribution we
come to really figure out anything
anymore from this data set on the other
hand this was a toy example only seven
rows so obviously we're going to lose a
lot amount of information trying to
group very different people thing ever
so I went ahead and did some experiments
I used
the standard machine learning data set
called
adult it contains information on
people's age on their education on the
ethnic background and the class value is
whether they earn more or less than
$50,000 a year
I used the rxd identification software
to perform and analyzing operations
I used the standard settings which is in
particular interesting it tries to
minimize information loss and I'm after
the enemy data set was analyzed I just
ran a logistic regression to figure out
if classified classification performance
suffers so on this in this plot you see
on the x-axis the different values for K
this goes up to a bit over 500 and on
the y axis you see classifier
performance I'm using here at the f1
measure so you want the higher the
number the better and we see that for
about up to K equals 50 we're still
pretty good we're not losing much we're
still reaching a similar F once as
previously afterwards it like had f1
starts dropping and it's quite much it
is basically at half of previous
performance for K around three hundred
one thing you should keep in mind that
this is for one specific data set and
for one specific classifier that doesn't
necessarily mean that this is
generalizable that K equals 50 is a good
value also what happens here I increase
the K a little bit and now suddenly the
f1 is absurdly high it's even higher
than what we initially set out for so
let's dig into this how did this happen
one thing I looked at first is how many
values we have for each attribute so we
said for example we could group ages
into ranges so if we have ages and years
we have let's say 100 possible value if
we have ranges of 10 years we only have
ten possibilities
so in this plot age is two across one
and we can see for K equals one we have
lots of different values for age and
already for K equals two these have been
squashed down to just a few age ranges
the next thing that is being squashed
down is the native country and we can
see what we expect the more K we have
the less for each of the attributes the
less information the less different
values are left we can also see
suppression happening in this data set
so for K equals one we have about 30,000
rows and as we can expect a few rows
every time we increase K will be
suppressed so in the end we turn out
with a little bit over 20,000 rows so at
first I thought we had way too much ass
oppression going on that there's maybe
only a few hundred rows in the data set
and that is why the everyone was just so
weird for high K but it turns out if we
look at this is K round about one
thousand two thousand three hundred this
is all that is left of the data set so
basically we have made a statistics we
have a bunch of smaller groups of
populations and very little class we
have dominating classes in most of these
groups very little groups where we
actually have two classes left so this
data set has nothing to do anymore
with the data set we had at the
beginning and we can't really compare
the f1 yeah that was fun but bad news
these methods they won't really work for
high dimensional sparse data sets let's
consider your Amazon and you want to
publish your data set one row for every
customer one column for the customers ID
let's have it a proper randomization not
just an md5 hash and then one column for
every article you sell and then you just
make a little cross for everything for
every article that purse that specific
customer has bought and
it is quite obvious that with such a
high dimensional data set you will have
a very hard time grouping people people
are not that similar there's such a wide
range of articles they could have bought
also we don't have quasi identifiers
anymore like like age or education right
now everything is that quasi identifier
as soon as you know a few things that
somebody bought you will be able to
uniquely identify that person that
person's row and figure out everything
that they bought and in fact this has
been done before and a famous example is
the Netflix price so Netflix published a
dataset containing information on
ratings that people had on the lid on
the platform and we should show that if
you only know to write things that
somebody gave and the date that they
gave that rating plus minus three days
you can uniquely identify 68% of the
people that means if you ask your
coworker on Monday what movies they
watched on Netflix and how they rated
them that weekend you there's a pretty
high likelihood you can figure out
everything else that that person has
watched on Netflix maybe a bit scarier
is the case of the mobile phone location
data so this these are data sets that
contain formation like when and where
did you make a call and when is only in
resolution of one hour here so it's not
even super detailed and this is data
that all mobile phone operators have
available and it turns out you only need
to know four of these spatial temporal
points to uniquely figure out for
ninety-five percent of people in this
data set all of their phone history and
because of this researchers have called
for an alternative understanding of
privacy going away from these quasi
identifiers equivalence groups and just
having this really strong notion that if
you're in the data set your privacy
should know your risk to your privacy
should not substantially increase this
is a bit fuzzy I think we there was an
sample it will be more obvious so
instead of releasing data itself we're
moving to a model of interactive queries
you cannot instead of making counting
how many what is the average rate of
people voting for be on the raw data set
you just have a query interface and you
can give this query a question you could
also ask how many people in puts them
voted for B and the answer you will get
is the actual result plus some
appropriate amount of noise it's quite
obvious why you need that noise assume
you know your friend from Potsdam is in
that dataset and you ask your query well
how many people in are there in Potsdam
one how many people inputs don't vote
for b1 well there you got your answer
what your friends what your friend would
vote for so you need to add this noise
to give different results that and so
the idea is that the query system keeps
a history of all such queries and make
sure that privacy is not the risk to
privacy does not increase unfortunately
most of this work is quite academic I'm
not aware of any practical system that
is in place and also we said earlier
right that we wanted to have we wanted
to publish raw data and what we are
doing now is quite near statistics but
on the plus side its statistic where you
can define the aggregate so you can you
your you're not at the mercy of the data
publisher what they considered is very
interesting
you can still formulate your questions
yourself and there has been work to
formulate existing machine learning
algorithms in terms of these queries
let's get back to the to the practical
side of things now unfortunately like I
told you I can't give you a
one-size-fits-all manual what you should
do is look at what data do you want to
protect and what happens if you don't
protect it what is the risk to your
customer is it risk of their is it
criminal risk is it in form a
like medical information based on that
you you should figure out what kind of
knowledge what methods could your
adversary potentially use and also think
about what is the use case of your data
do you want people to be able to
visually make visualizations or do you
just want to give some to be able to do
some statistics on the data and based on
these four questions you should also
consider after anonymization is there
even enough utility left is it worse
publishing the data set there's a few
Redflex you can look out for obviously
names addresses phone numbers locations
of any kind are critical remember
members of small populations we talked
about the older people previously if you
have a lot of if you have ages then
there will be only a few people of of
higher age in there and obviously look
out for untranslated text they could
continue information about the person
that you're not even aware of
I looked for standards that people use I
found unfortunately very little one of
the highest privacy standards I found is
the new medical laws in the US for
public medical data in response to this
medical breach that we talked about
earlier in Massachusetts now you can
only use the first three zip codes first
three digits of the zip code you are not
allowed to give dates as a full date
only years and you need to group people
ages 90-plus into one range and
obviously no names phone numbers in
Social Security numbers and the other
one I found this extra unfortunately
it's for statistics so if you look on
the internet you find there you will
find the Eurostat for example they have
a bunch of regulations on publishing
statistics which is not really what we
are talking about here in the census in
2011 and Germany there basically was
requirement for K and none on opt with k
equal through three so four for each
equivalent group they must
be at least Reaver three records
otherwise completely suppress those
records so for the video these are my
references and to summarize what is
insensitive to you is not necessarily
insensitive to somebody else
the best method you can choose is
dependent on your use case your threat
model there is unfortunately a trade-off
between anonymity and data utility and
many methods break down for high
dimensional data if you're a data
scientist you apply some of the methods
that I talked about today and you're
still unsure
maybe consult an expert thank you um hi
before you mentioned adding noise to the
data and how would you define doing that
out because obviously if you have one
person voting in past time the smaller
the data set the greater than or have to
add which then you have no data yes that
is true there is it's very academic work
and they have proven some upper bounds
let me just sec check if I will very
quickly find this on on what kind of
noise you need to add no I'm sorry I
can't I can't find out right now but
they're in their head yes the size of
the data set is definitely relevant and
there's mathematical proofs on how much
you need to add
when you talked about red flags that you
should have already mentioned
untranslated text so how would you
translate text like in a different
language well what would translate the
text well it means let's say you are a
researcher from Germany and most of the
data in there is German but then
suddenly somebody filled in the survey
with some Turkish you don't know what
that contains and unless you don't speak
Turkish so probably you should go to
somebody who speaks Turkish and make
sure that there's nothing in that text
that identifies people at the beginning
you had this slide with the graphs of
age groups not age groups the age and
the hopefully hood to pinpoint the
individuals and there was an interesting
peak there I have lots of slides yes
sorry yeah well well it seems like
there's many people of that age in the
US so this kind of morose demographics I
also found that that for Germany you're
safer if you're young because lots of
young people who are students for
example move to bigger cities and
generally USA for in bigger cities
because there's more people of your kind
around
yeah first of all thank you very much
for this very interesting talk I'm
wondering was the desert also changed
the way how we store data and let data
scientists access the data in our own
databases yeah so because as a data
scientist usually you have access to the
raw data yeah so we dis imply that we
should maybe also limit access to the
data scientists to blurry data yes that
might imply that I know there's some
works on databases that work with
differential privacy so basically you
have one trusted database and an
administrator but everybody who accesses
the database can only ask these kind of
interactive queries okay so I have most
of methods musician involves bundling
rare options and how to do so so to not
introduce biases not to erase
information from rare diseases places
we've not even leaving there etc that is
a very good question I don't think I
have an immediate answer to that I guess
you would want to when I talked earlier
about that you want to optimize for
something when you anonymize for example
for information loss I guess you could
define some measure of the biases in
your data that you don't want to lose
and use that as the criterion that
guides your optimization of of the data
set
maybe a generalization of this last
question in general if you have this
suppression when you have unique cases
in your data set sometimes they are the
most interesting ones the outliers and
in some sense I guess you gotta live
with that and also um there's different
schools of suppression so you don't
necessarily need to surpass the whole
role as I did right now you might just
want to suppress one of the attributes
and then maybe you're already able to
group that person with with some other
people and maybe that one you suppress
is not this outlier that you want to
pretend in the dataset okay there is
actually time for really the next
question can you give any advice on how
to anonymize graphs on maps so I have
the problem that I want to analyze maps
of companies I don't have any no I'm
sorry I know there's work I know there's
work in that area but I haven't read
into it